so it's a great honor for me to welcome
you here to this spring form event
sponsored by the program for economic
research in the world leaders forum my
name is david weinstein and i'm the
executive director of purr purrs main
functions are to foster economic
research and teaching at Columbia and to
project ideas from a kadeem into the
policy and business worlds as such /
aims to bring economic policy and
business leaders to Columbia in an
effort to help stimulate and interact
with our academic community this year
much of hers programmatic activities
have focused on finance when I'm
delighted to finish off the years with
today's event finance has been at the
center of much of the news over the past
year and not surprisingly it has also
been at the center of much of economic
research it's hard to think of a field
in which economics has not had more of
an impact fifty years ago modern
statistical finance was created through
the work of academic economists like
MIDI Glee on e.miller sharp and others
it's hard to imagine that until the
academic work of black and Scholes 40
years ago no one on Wall Street had the
ability to properly price stock options
and many of the other derivatives that
have been the center of the financial
crisis moreover as Fed and Treasury
officials intervened in the markets
following the crisis many of the terms
of the tarp were determined by pricing
models which are taught in our finance
classes hand-in-hand with the rise of
financial economics has been the rise of
finance itself in 1947 the finance
industry accounted for only two point
three percent of u.s. gdp today it has
more than tripled in size to 7.7 percent
in 1990 there were 610 hedge
with 38 billion dollars under management
by 2007 there were more than 7,000 funds
with approximately one point nine
trillion dollars under management while
world GDP in 2006 stood at approximately
forty seven trillion dollars the
capitalization of the world stock
markets was ten percent larger or fifty
one trillion dollars the value of all
derivative contracts outstanding was ten
times larger than world GDP in 2007 so
it's therefore not surprising that
financial crises have global
implications perhaps what is most
surprising is our own surprise at the
onset of the crisis in 2007 far from
being rare events there have been 18
major banking crises in the developed
world alone that's the developed world
since the end of the Second World War or
roughly one every three years with major
crises hitting countries like spain
norway finland sweden japan etc our
surprise perhaps reflects the parochial
nature of Americans who ignored crises
in other countries with a sense that we
were too smart to let something happen
here understanding what happened and
what we should do to prevent further
crises is therefore critical in order to
maintain stable growth and in the spirit
were delighted that President Lee
Bollinger and his staff have made this
important lecture part of this year's
world leaders forum president Bollinger
is here obviously and will introduce our
distinguished speaker thank
thank you all for joining us this
evening I'd like to extend a special
thanks to David and his colleagues at
the program for economic research
tonight's co-sponsor as you just heard
for playing a critical role in bringing
this together one of the things we hope
for students when they come to columbia
is that they check their preconceptions
at the 116th street gate and open their
minds to new perspectives new
experiences and new people they might
never have encountered or considered it
is one of the best and most attractive
arguments for coming to the greatest
most global of American cities for
college or graduate school it is our
essential role and responsibility to
provide a venue for open conversation on
almost any topic in a society that has
chosen to make free speech and debate a
higher value than anyplace else in the
world and perhaps ever our world leaders
forums are just one way that we do that
at Columbia which in the span of a
single month can mean an open exchange
with one of America's allies in French
President Nicolas Sarkozy then with the
nation's highest ranking military
officer chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff Admiral Mike Mullen or tonight
with one of the global economies most
important business leaders Citigroup CEO
and four-time Columbia alumnus Vikram
Pandit today is our third recent world
leaders forum on the economy a topic
that is rightly at the top of concern
and conversation not only across our own
country but across the globe in the wake
of the worst financial crisis since the
Great Depression of the 1930s just two
weeks ago on this stage Columbia
economist and Nobel laureate Joe
Stiglitz that a conversation with
Commodity Futures Trading Commission
Chair Gary Gensler and former sec chair
Arthur Levitt and earlier this year we
listen to Bill Dudley President of the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York
and of course there have been many
conferences and seminars classes and
conversations across the campus over the
past year at our law and business
schools our schools of journalism and
public affairs college and engineering
schools all seeking to understand what
happened to our global financial system
and why and what should be done about it
now our distinctive role is to bring
scholarly perspective to this historical
moment but we're obviously not alone in
asking these important questions indeed
since the moment of the meltdown in
September 2008 and perhaps even more
today with the benefit of hindsight
those responsible for our most powerful
financial institutions have come under a
new wave of much-needed public scrutiny
and discussion as this week's hearings
and debate in our nation's capital amply
illustrate we are at a real inflection
point in history on financial regulation
and a new perspective and a change of
heart after a long period in which it
became widely accepted let us recognize
that free market should be left free to
correct themselves and that they would
in fact do so there were voices of
dissent to be sure contrarians to the
housing bubble regulators and
legislators who doubted the wisdom of
repealing the glass-steagall act more
than a decade ago journalists who
investigated the increasing leveraged
academics who saw the bubble and
predicted its bursting and early warning
shots of enron and worldcom and yet we
saw over the past decade what we saw was
fundamentally a broad failure of
knowledge and information a failure to
understand the realities of economic
activity at a very basic level a failure
to see linkages and connections and a
failure to understand the elements of
mass psychology these are the kinds of
questions the universities are supposed
to be concerned with and so from a
positive perspective
there's still a lot to do and thank God
for Columbia into this heated Malstrom
comes the cool measured indeed academic
voice of Vikram Pandit who had the
impeccable timing of being named CEO of
Citigroup in December of 2007 when the
troubles in the global financial system
may have already become manifest but not
to their disastrous existential scope
the challenges Vikram inherited came to
a head on his watch and Citigroup
appeared at one point to be on the brink
of collapse stock prices plummeted from
fifty dollars a share in 2007 to briefly
trading at under one dollar a share the
bank was through was the recipient of 45
billion dollars in federal funds through
tarp for which we the taxpayers took on
a more than twenty-seven percent
ownership while the strategies and
positions precipitating citigroup's
troubles proceeded Vikram's leadership
he came under fire for not moving fast
enough some openly questioned whether he
was the right person to tackle the
enormous challenges of such a large
company which frankly all came as a
surprise to those of us familiar with
Vikram Pandit powerful intellect and
enormous capacity for strategic thinking
as the New York Times business section
recently said there was even talk of
nationalization a move that would have
wiped out shareholders and cost mr.
Pandit his job and his legacy fittingly
the story goes on New York magazine
called mr. Pandit the most powerless
powerful man on Wall Street today mr.
Pandit is still at the hem helm and
through a series of small but important
moves the article goes on he is quietly
asserting his influence piece by piece
is shedding complex businesses like the
insurance and retail broke
Judith's shrinking the bank's balance
sheet and stabilizing its finances close
quote and just last week Citigroup
reported a 4.4 billion dollar profit for
the first quarter and according to news
reports had its call must quietest
shareholder meeting in some time now
city has repaid 20 billion to the
taxpayers with interest and the federal
government has begun steps to sell at
City stock that many expect it will earn
a profit on the taxpayer investment we
all see this we all have an interest in
seeing this institution continue to
return to vitality here it is important
to point out that Vikram has taken a
notable stance among his peers in the
industry by publicly supporting the
white house's robust financial reform
proposals as was reported yesterday he
sent a letter to President Obama also a
Columbia Graduate stating as he did
before Congress last month quote this is
Vikram speaking I believe banks should
not speculate with their capital I
believe in transparency of markets I
believe derivatives should be cleared
and settled centrally I believe there
should be a strong federal consumer
authority to protect consumer interests
we must have a strong systemic regulator
with respect to compensation we need a
merit-based system driven by long-term
performance and it is essential to have
a level playing field across the global
financial industry all of this i'm sure
more we will hear this evening before
joining Citigroup Vikram Pandit was the
founding member and chairman of the old
lane of old lane a hedge fund and a
private equity fund manager that was
later acquired by city is also served as
president and CEO of Morgan Stanley's
institutional securities and investment
banking businesses but most importantly
before going into the business world
Vikram was an accomplished scholar and
taught at Indiana University as well as
Columbia Business School as I said at
the beginning Vikram Pandit as many
times
lum bein he received undergraduate and
master's degrees in electrical
engineering here as well as both an MBA
and a PhD in business among the wide
array of leadership roles he has taken
at this institution he has served with
great distinction as it actively engaged
University trustee since 2003 I
apologize for these long introductions
to get Vikram up to the podium but we
are grateful for all the quiet ways he
engages with Columbia proud to have him
back on campus in this more visible role
please welcome me or join me in
welcoming our friend and our alumnus and
one of the most important people in the
world today Citigroup CEO Vikram Pandit
but thank you thank you very much mr.
president thank you for that wonderful
introduction thank you for making me
relive the last two years and i really i
really think the introduction was rather
complete should we go to Q&A what do you
think anyway it's wonderful to be here
back at Columbia obviously this
community holds a very special place in
my heart and it always will when I first
came to the campus in 1973 I was 16
years old and so I literally grew up in
Morningside Heights now I've got to
admit it took me some time I spent
nearly 10 years here I really do want to
thank the University for its patients
what struck me about Columbia was that
you were really never far from the real
world and leaves very correct and saying
that Columbia is an incredible diverse
place with a large international student
body a global university and by the way
there was never any pressure to conform
here and sometimes there were endless
debates and each of us had to find our
own way and in many many ways I left the
university extremely well trained for
the world that i'm in i was also one of
those people who was fortunate enough to
find my calling early in life I didn't
really have a game plan but I guess good
things happened if you are well trained
by University and doing the kind of work
that you like and so today I'm here as a
grateful alumnus of the University and
of course also as the chief executive
officer city which is one of the world's
great financial institutions we're a
company of two hundred and sixty-five
thousand people in a hundred and sixty
plus jurisdictions we have more than 200
million customer accounts we serve
clients big and small including 99% of
the fortune 500 and we call ourselves
America's global bank and by the way
most days it's a great job
but every day it's an exciting and
challenging job with a sense of purpose
because city has the ability to open up
opportunities for millions of people
around the world and to be a force for
positive change as Lee said I've had
this job since december two thousand
seven and during a trying and difficult
period for millions of people i came
aboard during the financial crisis city
lost billions of dollars we needed help
from the US government our shareholders
suffered so there are employees and
sadly we had to let thousands of good
people go a lot of Americans are hurting
these days as well and for many many of
them their pain is worse than anything
that we've had to deal with that city
they're hurt they're angry and much of
that anger is directed at the financial
services industry and I don't blame them
it's easy to see why the industry
contributed to our nation's economic
slump which is brought about or ten
percent unemployment rate and two
foreclosures that force people out of
their homes ordinary Americans think
bankers don't understand them worse
worse yet they believe we don't care
about them and that's not a good place
to be for anybody for our country us any
of us here in this room so over the last
two years we've been working very hard
to remake city from top to bottom and
we're making much progress we've got
much to do but we've also done quite a
bit and to fully succeed we must take
the responsibility for showing them
showing the American people that we do
care city is committed to serving our
clients interests helping individuals
and families in financial distress
promoting economic recovery and
supporting the reform of our financial
system today we find ourselves in a very
new position of financial strength from
which to pursue these goals
so this evening I would like to share
with you how we got to this point one
banks journey through the financial
crisis I want to share with you what
we've learned how we're different today
our views on how regulation needs to
change and our commitment to what we
call responsible finance and I fully
realize that we have to live what we say
and make our words become actions but
that's my job let me start by addressing
what I think went wrong in the markets
leading up to the financial crisis city
like other financial institutions was a
creature of its environment that
pre-crisis environment was characterized
by a vibrant financial market it seemed
to offer an abundant bottomless pool of
financing and capital thanks in large
part to securitisations the rise of the
shadow banking system and the acronyms
they spun off like CDOs SI vs and others
in that environment aggressive
procyclical T defined the mentality very
smart people defined and measured risks
in ways that made traditional concepts
of pure primitive the markets convince
themselves that Rick said that risk was
actually declining shareholders came to
expect their companies to generate the
high returns they saw other companies
churning out consolidation became
synonymous with strategic success and
size mattered more than ever market
players even assured themselves that
there was suddenly new financial
engineering that could transform
illiquid assets into liquid form and all
the while we were assured that that this
time is different and David Weinstein
talked about this this is a phrase that
the world has heard and heeded all too
easily not only since the Second World
War but all through the 1800s
1900s and each time on the eve of a
major upheaval in the markets City
rapidly grew both its balance sheet and
off-balance sheet assets to historic
highs in both size and leverage and the
wisdom of acid diversification gave way
to concentration in ever larger amounts
of real estate and consumer lending as a
result at the peak of the housing market
city like many others was highly exposed
to US housing and the US consumer city
and many other financial institutions to
comfort from the fact that the many of
the securities that they held were
highly rated and they were insured and
in retrospect we know that this was
false comfort so what did we do at City
to pull ourselves out of this crisis to
build a new city and to learn and to
remember the lessons of the turmoil that
we've lived through over the last two
years after I became CEO my management
team and I focused on three immediate
priorities financial strength strategic
clarity and cultural change we moved
extremely fast to shore up the financial
strength of City and we succeeded we
raised tens of billions of dollars of
capital since our peak in 2007 we
reduced our assets by over half a
trillion dollars we completed 43
divestitures our annualized costs are
down 13 billion dollars and
unfortunately we had to lower our
headcount by 110,000 people and by the
end of last year city was amongst the
strongest banks in the world by most of
the critical measures on capital and
liquidity along the way we received
additional help from the US taxpayers in
their form of tarp investment and City
by the end of last year we had paid back
that investment with a substantial
return
for taxpayers however and I've said this
again again I will continue to say this
publicly we still owe the taxpayer a
large debt of gratitude which we are
committed to repaying by remaining and
active contributor to the American
economy and the communities that we
serve strategic clarity was I second
priority and that's because the company
was in numerous diverse businesses
around the world many of them recently
acquired we were not a unified company
with a unified culture consequently we
initiated a process of soul-searching we
examined the global environment not just
the immediate problems but also the
longer-term forces at work including the
rise of emerging markets the rapid
growth of affluent middle class outside
the US the importance of exports to US
economic growth we also asked ourselves
two of the most basic questions of all
first why do clients really need us and
second what are we really best at as a
company and here's what we decided first
to return to the basics of banking city
had tried hard to be all things to all
people we decided city will not be a
supermarket to be a bank means to take
deposits make loans provide payment
systems and custodial services finance
trade facilitate capital flows through
trading and underwriting all with
confidence and trust by focusing on
banking basics City will be ultimately
forty percent smaller in size from its
peak in 2007 we also resolve to
concentrate on why we're distinctive and
why clients need us our most distinctive
competitive advantage is city's unique
ability to connect the world through an
unparalleled
international presence in addition we
changed our business model from one of
capital deployment to client centricity
we vowed to focus squarely on client
interests and that's by the way much
more than a platitude because banks and
other financial companies including city
often strayed from this principle
transactions trumped relationships and
often with an emphasis on trading for
the bank's own accounts a best bank
serves the interest of its shareholders
and employees by concentrating on what
is best for its customers and on
building relationships with them and
that is a clear clear lessons of dis
financial crisis we also recognize that
our strategy could only be good as good
as our people Financial Services is a
people business we had to make some
critical changes in personnel and senior
management and in the leadership of our
businesses we had to have a world-class
team sharply focused on the basics of
banking in addition City made changes to
its board of directors including the
recruitment of individuals with deep
experience in banking and other relevant
fields and finally we resolved never to
compromise our financial strength again
it has to be at the core of our strategy
we made extensive changes in cities risk
management systems established tough new
financial discipline and return to
traditional more conservative
assessments of risk let me talk about a
third priority cultural change clearly
something that's much more intangible
but to me it's absolutely essential and
it is at the center of what I'm going to
talk about next a sound culture
internalizes strategy and drives
constructive behavior every day a
culture of responsibility is a very
powerful force beyond rules and beyond
regulations to help guard against bad
judgments temptations to push the
envelope and the impulse to act and
self-interest first
so we at City are creating a unified
culture that's built on the values of
responsible finance no one including me
wants to see a repeat of 2008 2009 but
here's the problem in 5 10 20 or 30
years people in the midst of a volatile
economic bubble are unlikely to see
beyond the illusions that creates their
memories of what happened 2008-2009 will
be dim maybe even non-existent and they
could repeat history they could succumb
to all too familiar pressures that we
just saw over the last many years to
them risk and market will appear to be
coming down creating pressure to
increase risk leverage and take more
risk shareholders will demand more and
more profits as they view mounting
returns for other shareholders clients
will say to their financial advisers
what's wrong with you guys my friends
advisor is getting him thirty percent a
year and media and pundits on Wall
Street will say to CEOs you are just too
risk-averse you're living in the dark
ages get with it management's board of
directors and government officials will
all feel these conflicting pressures and
when they react they will turn up the
heat within the whole system and that
climate pseudo experts and even people
who are generally smart and wise will
reassure everyone this time it's
different just as they have repeatedly
done in the past and we know it won't be
different so what do we do does history
have to continue to clone itself how can
we make sure the lessons that we've
learned are embedded in our collective
memory so that we can at least mitigate
future crises we thought about this a
lot we spent a lot of time thinking
about this for City how do I create an
institution for the future we thought
about it for the system how do we make
sure the system
internalizes the learning and I know of
only two answers one is a regulation to
try to hard wire the learning from this
era into the financial system and the
other is culture each financial
institution can create a culture of
responsibility but let's be honest
neither answer is likely to be complete
history has clearly shown that there is
not a correlation between the enactment
of more laws and the end of great
financial crises and by the way smart
people with self-interest will always
find a way around the letter of the law
we do need a new global order for
regulators bankers administrators that
will either substitute or supplement
existing frameworks with the goal to
stay ahead of crises realistically the
goal is not to stop crises but to
mitigate them and have the tools
necessary to effectively manage them so
one of the reasons I'm really here
tonight is that where I'm at the right
University with the right group of
people the right minds some of the best
minds anywhere for addressing the
question in the world and the country
needs your best thinking on this how do
we create a global banking and
regulatory structure that constantly
enables us to learn and stay ahead of
crises how do we ensure that there's
clarity of principles by which to run
the system with continuous updating of
laws regulation and other tools to take
into account new products new ways of
doing business and new technologies can
we change the approach to evaluate
whether this time it's really different
or can we even hope to let me go back to
city's responsibility I believe a strong
culture of responsibility is a
significant part of the answer its
purpose is to ensure we serve client
interests and we're a force for positive
change in the world I should point out
that in my experience the type of
business you are in
significantly affects culture there is
truth in the notion for example that
banking has one kind of culture and
retail brokerage as another kind of
culture it's very different within a
diversified financial services company
you can find a variety of different
cultures and I think therefore by
returning to the basics of banking we're
helping set the fundamental tone for the
culture that we want at City I believe
that the systemic just that the systemic
pursuit or responsible finance is
ultimately the way to embed and City an
institutional memory that deeply impacts
the behavior of both current and future
employees in all our businesses and at
all levels are accompanied it is
intended to guide city's behavior when
private economic interest conflicts with
public interest and it's precise meaning
will evolve with changing times and
changing definitions of what's in the
public's interests and perhaps it offers
some basis for cultural change in a
larger scale in the system as a whole
today we have three core principles of
responsible finance first cities
activities must contribute to the
economy and to the global economy and
today said you must contribute to
America's recovery by practicing the
basics of banking we assist people in
distress help businesses grow support
the financing of public projects around
the world for example since the
beginning of the US housing crisis in
2007 we have helped 900,000 homeowners
in their efforts to avoid foreclosure we
lend actively to businesses of all size
with a special focus of small and
mid-sized companies that have trouble
obtaining the financing they need we're
leaders and financing the export of
American goods and services and we're
one of the biggest sources of financing
for schools hospitals and other vital
infrastructure projects the second
principle is that that our businesses
must be all about our clients
our products and services must promote
customer choice and control over their
financial lives that's why for instance
we've had some of the industry's more
most bro consumer policies on fees and
overdrafts it's why we invest tens of
millions of dollars in educational
programs that provide scholarships for
college education as well as counseling
and instruction on financial matters for
low-income individuals and families and
it's also the reason why our strategy
and business model are designed to use
our capital for clients versus
proprietary trading the third principle
is that will be a strong advocate for
systemic safety and for forward-looking
global financial reform that by the way
starts with making sure our houses in
order always and that we run our
businesses prudently but goes beyond
that and I have publicly and often
advocated reform that will protect
consumer interests and strengthen
confidence in our financial markets and
institutions the entire city
organization around the world has joined
me in this endeavor and the fundamental
principles are formed that we advocate
today are exactly the ones that the
president talked about last week and I
think Lee mentioned some of these little
bit earlier but banks should be banks
focused on serving clients banks should
not speculate with their capital markets
need to be transparent derivatives
should be cleared centrally and settled
centrally we need a strong federal
consumer authority to protect consumer
interests we should end once and for all
the phenomena of too big to fail we
should have a strong systemic regulator
it is essential absolutely essential to
have a level playing field across the
global financial industry and we need a
merit-based compensation system driven
by long-term performance we believe
these principles the regulatory reform
can create a stronger financial system
and bring Wall Street
and Main Street closer together still
the broader challenge is to create a
global banking and regulatory system
that constantly learns from experiences
and stays ahead of crisis and let me
remind you again that this is where I
hope the world gets help from some of
the superb and well-trained minds here
at this university and obviously we're
thinking long term now and then I
contemplate what city will look like in
five years and 10 years 25 years 35
years from now and I don't know what the
markets are going to look like or who
our competitors are going to be or how
the economy will fare in twenty twenty
or twenty thirty five but I do believe
the right culture will serve us well
someone said that a corporate culture is
nothing more than how we do things
around here and our culture will be
shaped by responsible finance my
responsibility a city is to build that
culture and that will be my most
valuable legacy at the institution both
city in Colombia are great institutions
and they've been around for a while and
our histories are quite intertwined this
world-renowned university was founded at
King's College in 1754 in lower
Manhattan its students included
Alexander Hamilton our first our
nation's first Treasury secretary who
went on to found the bank of United
States when that Bank lots lost its
charter in 1812 a group of merchants
formed the city bank of new york today
Citigroup and took over the national
banks old headquarters on Wall Street in
1812 Columbia and citibank have survived
the war of 1812 with citibank having
opened its doors only two days before
the war survived the Civil War the
financial panics of the late 19th
century and the great depression because
they were blessed with leaders who acted
as stewards of great institutions during
hard times people who fear
bank failures brought their money to
citibank because we were known as
prudent bankers our reputation was quite
literally our most valuable asset so
today whether we study or teach at
Columbia or work at City we do so
because of the integrity and dedication
of those who came before us and we owe
them a great deal we can repay that debt
by enhancing the quality and reputation
of these great institutions and by using
their power to make a war make the world
a better place and that city that is my
purpose as we move forward so mr.
president thank you for inviting me to
speak here today this wonderful group I
thank you very much all of you and we're
ready to take questions
so thank you very much Rick from I think
I'll just ask one or two questions and
and then we'll open it up for people to
go to the microphones I a complicated
question to ask at the beginning not
surprisingly i suppose i'm very struck
by the way in which you characterized
how the world got to the point it did in
2007 and how that world is likely to
come again so what you described was a a
world in which actors whatever they
thought initially convince themselves of
things that turned out to be not true or
they felt trapped in a system where they
had to act contrary to what they thought
him hoped they could get out early
enough so that's the bubble it's a mass
hysteria it's a it's a psychological
problem and to the people like me who
think about constitutional law this is
not a new phenomenon we have a bill of
rights because democracy loses its
bearings people become frightened rather
than a billion and and create market
bubbles they become fearful and they
oppress minorities and treat people
badly and as a way of dealing with that
we put the bill of rights to a
constitution we took the power to
enforce that or deal with that problem
out of the political system almost
entirely lifetime appointments for
judges a culture of supporting the
constitutional rights and so on my
question to you is if you were sort of
in an ideal world forget
about the politics of the moment and you
were trying to have a constitution a
bill of rights for the financial bubbles
what kind of social structure do we need
to help us stop that from happening now
the Fed is not there it's still but what
what kind of structure do we need what
tools are there well I would start by
recommending against lifetime employment
for CEOs I don't think that's a good
idea but I think that is the question
and there are a couple different aspects
of bubbles we need to think about there
is the psychology part but there is also
an informational counterpart somewhere
along the way the markets just did not
have the information necessary to absorb
what was going on and therefore give the
markets a chance to succeed and we found
that out here I mean we did not we knew
nothing about the extent of the CD s
portfolio credit default swap portfolios
are some of the institutions that
particular market went from a few
billion dollars early two thousands to
over trillions of dollars in a very
short period of time by the way lots of
issues against transparencies in the
securitisation market so there are
issues about social structure we can
target to talk about but there is one
fundamental principle I think it's
absolutely critical which is that around
the world we have to endeavor to always
change rules always change laws to
ensure we have continuous transparency
now that's easier said than done because
there are lots of vested interests
behind not wanting transparency and by
the way some of the dealers who deal in
these markets are the first ones to say
how does it help but but if there is one
principle that we have to abide by it is
give capital markets chance to work and
they have no chance of
working unless they have information
that they need to clear that's that's
the first thing now it gets very
complicated the reason it gets
complicated is that we do live in a
political economy and and you will know
also non Leah as a student a
constitution but a student of history
that's one of the biggest changes in the
constitution happen around economic
disasters as well or the biggest changes
in laws and or regulation happen around
when when economies turn so the question
of how you institutionalize some sort of
learning and you use the Bill of Rights
etc to to make it happen is incredibly
difficult because we live in a global
market yet each country is going to have
its own ideas about the kind of
political economy it wants to run
witness what's going on in Europe today
and that in that scenario it's very
difficult to come up with something that
works the closest thing we have is the
Federal Reserve Bank the closest thing
anybody has in the central banks around
the world but those two are a bank in
every country could you could we
hypothec a tag lobel central bank but
how would it work so these are some real
practical issues these are not questions
of theory these are questions of
practice right and I keep coming back to
saying if we follow one principle which
is the principle of transparency and
take the pain that goes with that we can
be a lot better off than where we are it
not going to solve all the issues could
there are going to be market failures or
we go a long way down the road you are a
person who I've always felt the crumb
really understands the grass the kind of
essence of what's happening the forces
at work and and sort of is able to think
about how they will play out or should
lay out and when you say I'm also struck
by your say we need a level playing
field in the global
economy and what you just said about the
need for coordination across countries
how obviously sovereignty and our
notions of sovereignty are a major part
of what must give way I mean this is not
possible to build the kind of global
economy were in the process doing with
the same degree of sovereignty that that
states assume a do you think that's
right be do how do you see that
unfolding obviously sovereignty is a
political question and and it doesn't
matter what I think it's a matter of the
people in the country think what they
want and so that is always going to be
the case that's not going to change but
think about think about sovereignty or
rather governance in a very different
way what are we learning from the
capital markets now here's there is a
there is a wonderful real-life example
we're going through in Europe where a
group of countries got together and say
no individual currency one we've given
up national sovereignty of printing
local money but we have adopting one
currency and then we have examples of
certain countries who actually have lost
control therefore of their credit
ratings their financing because they
can't print money they are part of the
Europe yep now the ultimate governance
mechanism in some ways here is the
bondholders who own sovereign debt or
certain European company countries are
telling them what they need to do and so
ironically yes there's political
sovereignty but the capital markets tend
to take over economic governments very
well and that's the phenomena we're
going to have to live with and therefore
the need for global coordination and the
need for really thinking about the
financial side of the equation or
countries around the world is that
ultimately the cat
markets will speak and as they speak
they will control your economy and
they'll control what you need to do and
and but learning through that and
getting there is a difficult process I
must say that having gone from g72 g20
is absolutely terrific right as and
that's a great vehicle to start with it
may not be complete it may not be
perfect but it's a very positive step
but your thought here is that
sovereignty is going to give way or
they're going to be huge pressures on
sovereignty but it's not going to come
from a global financial system to
respond to global it's going to come
from markets demanding that countries
behave in certain ways that they may not
want to and they're going to exceed some
of their sovereignty I mean that that's
what you I think and and the history of
that is clear will you look at some of
the countries in Latin America is on the
countries in Europe bond holders are
telling countries here's how you
prudently manage your economy yeah and
so all of a sudden it's more than about
what the population thinks it's about
what it is that the capital markets tank
because you need the financing to keep
the economy going so let me that's just
one final question from from me and it's
a light question just like the others
yeah do you enjoy your day I mean do you
really like going to work and is this a
okay let's go to yes yes thank you I was
very gratified sir to hear your opinions
of how banks should be run at the same
time if you listen to yesterday's
hearings in Congress seems to me that
Goldman Sachs is exactly the opposite
views that you have and I wonder if a
you could explain that and be if you
could have some benevolent influence on
the thinking of the executives of
Goldman Sachs which I frankly think are
rather criminal well you know you're not
going to be surprised if I don't comment
that what I will say though is that we
got to go back to the regulatory
principles that I spoke off that I
talked about Lee talked about them that
is the closest thing to Bill of Rights
that you're going to get and what it
says is transparency matters disclosure
matters responsibility matters and by
the way the SEC and the regulators are
really thinking through the concept of
information because when you look at the
global financial markets it's not only
about regulating products regulating
structures regulating institutions
ultimately you need regulation of
information and so I hope through this
process as we go through it when you get
to the other side will get to a better
market thank you thank you yes on this
side Thank You mr. Pender for coming
today um you mentioned a few times that
banks should not speculate and there's
one lesson I then at Columbia is there's
no specular there's no difference
between speculation and investment and
you seem to have a clear definition of
the boundary between the two so I wonder
what's your definition and do consider
CDOs and srvs as speculation thank you
okay I think you know again this is a
that's a very interesting question
important question and by the way
exactly the kind of area that that
thoughtful academics can really
contribute to I'll tell you there's a
difference between speculation and
serving clients clearly true if you
commit capital to help clients that's
clearly in the context of the business
that you're in and that's true if you
make a loan that's true if you provide
them liquidity if they want to sell
something if you commit capital to
markets because they are dysfunctional
and that you actually have a market
making business that's consistent with
the business model that you have I think
what is not consistent necessarily with
the business model is to have a group of
people sitting back somewhere in the
room
and who are actually not dealing with
your clients but they're using the
company's capital the bank's capital and
dealing with everybody else on the
street and running portfolios of
investments because they believe that by
doing that you can earn a rate of return
now you know I don't want to get into
philosophy but I look at that and I say
that that is not the purpose of the bank
there are lots of other institutions
David wants and Weinstein talked about
1.9 trillion of hedge fund ask lots of
different places that that can happen it
doesn't necessarily have a role in the
back now if it has a role it's a limited
role in the context of using your
capital to really understand how markets
work to create strategies create
products for or clients so there it's
it's the ultimate client-oriented role
but that's a very clear distinction in
mind my mind there is not a confusion on
that yes dr. panda thank you again for
joining us here I have two questions
that relate to financial industry reform
one is internal with regard to corporate
governance and one is about some of
those specific proposals so with regard
to corporate governance I wonder if you
can comment on what kinds of measures
banks can take to resolve the tension
between the incentives of risk managers
and those of profit seekers within the
bank itself and then the second question
about the specific proposals both the
House bill and the dog bill contained
proposals for resolution funds that
could aid in the crisis management I was
curious if you can comment on those
which our thoughts are on those yeah
yeah I think I think compensation is a
is a significant question again it's not
the theory it's the practice of
compensation but here is very simple
design a compensation system as
economists that avoids moral hazard
would get it I mean we understand that
we understand but and by the way the
last time it worked for certain
financial firms like investment banks
were was when they were private
companies when there were private
companies governments in and moral
hazard and compensation worked
beautifully well and so the intention of
where one has to go with this given that
compensations levels can be large is to
see what can you do to mimic some of
private partnership aspects and
compensation so you get those handcuffs
and it is long-term performance etc but
ultimately it comes down to subjective
evaluations and that it is exactly the
kind of process which we're spending a
lot of time on the regulators are
spending a lot of time on that's
important because what they're going to
do is look at the structure and say I
like it I don't like it if I don't like
it you can do it but your capital
requirement goes up dramatically because
you're a riskier firm so there are lots
of different ways of getting at it but
again it's a it's not the theory it's
the practice it's difficult but we're
going to evolve to the right answers on
that your second question was about the
fund or you know that's that's probably
one of the areas that evokes a lot of
different reactions from people in the
g20 and for variety of different reasons
because you know they're in by the way
there is there is lots of questions
around that even in academics should you
have an ex ante fund should you have an
ex post fun how do you define insurance
what are you going to get as a bank in
exchange for getting that insurance how
do you to make sure there's no moral it
is really complicated to think about
that in the right way and therefore it
is one that probably is going to take
the most amount of work to think through
to the extent that we've been through
this crisis to the extent that
everybody's kind of learned and the
memories are fresh I don't think I don't
think it's a issue of urgent
decision-making importance it is an
important one but I hope that we'll take
the time to think through it rather than
rush to judgment this with the regards
to the Supervisory capital assessment
program did the 5.5 billion dollar scalp
offer aid citibank in its recovery and
and do you think banks trust us should
be imposed every two years or just once
one one of the major players players
fails
lehman brothers in the recent financial
crisis I think the let me see if I
answered all together one of the one of
the good things to come out of this
crisis is the need for a systemic
regulator then again you have
sovereignty issues one for every country
or where you know those are important
issues but let's say that a systemic
regulator that can actually gather the
information because again it's about
transparency and not everything that
needs to be transparent maybe
transparent the market but it could be
transparent to somebody watching even
that's not perfect what's the closest
thing we can get to a information based
sort of decision making process that
information is best understood when you
run what if scenarios and so stress cast
you can call them that but they're
nothing more than what if scenarios and
I think a good bank good financial
Esther should be running what if
scenarios constantly okay what if you
know scenarios sorry a the thing is this
was conducted through several government
agencies and do youth so do you think
you need an outside player to actually
look at those what if scenarios that
might not be as comprehensively just
match by by the bank's internal risk
dept yeah I mean I think I think we
that's that's an answer that's a
solution on the other hand I don't think
the problem was because the bank's
numbers were different than some of the
else's numbers in some cases members
weren't there in some cases they're just
wrong in some cases nobody expected
housing prices to go down forty percent
by the way if they did you would never
had a bubble so it's it's less about
that but I think the process was really
important running the what-if scenarios
and by the way there's always going to
be a scenario you missed we know that
which is one of the points that makes
this such a difficult exercise but I
think it's a good move it's a good move
and it's the right thing but the water
scenarios are not only about risk but
one of the issues is by the is that you
have
jurisdictional issues around the world
where laws are different if something
goes wrong it's not clear the same
bankruptcy laws apply around the world
and the what-if scenarios are also
against where is your capital trap where
is the money trap how are these
contracts going to be negative there's a
lot of issues surrounding that but it's
the right approach yes just to have two
more questions high five I have two
questions so the first is for a bank
there's for a bank like citibank which
was sort of rescued by the government
and which I ended up diluting its share
so much what do you think is the best
method for companies that had to you
know have their shares have their stock
deluded so much you know in terms of
things like reverse splits or stock
buybacks by the point citibank lee
what's the best method to to fix that or
to solve or to change that and my second
question is should financial regulation
get passed in some form what do you
think the role of big banks in the
future will be do you think that they'll
have to be some sort of re equilibrium
between the number of small banks and
big banks in the world and let me start
backward I think the financial services
industry is one place where there is
constant consolidation fragmentation
constant constant constant yes you will
read reach a new equilibrium and by the
way we need strong financial reform
let's get that clear we need it we need
it fast you talked about City how are we
going to get our stock up and the answer
is we're going to earn well money on
with stockdale loosen in general well I
think I mean the stock dilution is an
economic concept it's happened it's done
and therefore the only way to deal with
it is a restore value and the only way
to restore value is by creating economic
value by doing the right things that's
the answer you could do stock splits and
there are all kinds of pros and cons for
it but the fact that you own two shares
versus one share doesn't change what the
value is what you own so there and there
are there are stock buybacks and other
things you can look at but the
fundamental course of action is run your
business correctly and start creating
economic value that's the best antidote
the dilution okay now we have three
people left
and why do we just if you say your
questions very quickly we'll just take
all three questions and then Vikram can
sort of remember them and answer them
thank you my question was on the rating
agency what what kind of reform would
you suggest for the sector being blamed
a lot for the financial crisis okay next
all right a city group was formed i
believe by a merger between travelers
group and citibank which at the time was
a violation of the glass-steagall act so
do you think the repeal of
glass-steagall did really contribute to
the crisis or did it actually may be
helped commercial banks because they had
that buffer of commercial deposits okay
rating agencies glass-steagall and my
question is what is Citibank Bank are
sorry citigroup's position on the
proposed student loan reform as proposed
by President Obama student loans okay
okay I forgot rating agencies well you
know they got it wrong too what can you
say we understand that day understand
that where they're really good at is in
rating companies with assets and
liabilities and businesses and earnings
and where they got it wrong was in
rating financial engineered products but
they've learned from it and so I think
you're going to have a you're going to
have more robust rating agencies
companies rating agency companies on the
other side what were the other two
glass-steagall student loans yes first
of all let us talk about student loans
we have a large a very large student
loan business and and the basic change
on student loans is that government
guaranteed loans are issued by the
government going forward versus going
through companies like savvy may
ourselves or nelnet or people of that
sort who used to make it you know it's
one or the other it really to me it's
fine the biggest goal to me is make sure
we have student loans and that we got
students who have the ability to get
money I think the legislation
is that so I'm happy with that glass p I
bet she was asking about international
student loans it's that correct or not
no thank you and and the last one is
glass-steagall and regulation you know
everything that happened would have
happened could have happened even
without glass-steagall being repealed
that's the irony of this thing so people
think about it that way and I can
understand why people think about it but
to me it's really less about
glass-steagall but a need for strong
regulatory reform in the way we just
talked about if we do that I think we
get to the right place on banks not
using capital speculate banks not using
deposits to skip to speculate to have
having the clarity of what banks are in
business for I think that goes the wrong
way so less about glass-steagall more
about let's get this kind of a reform
bill passed really importantly become
you have been you have made major
contributions to this institution over a
long period of time and this is a
wonderful to have you here and to have
this special contribution today thanks
for coming